hi everyone
welcome to this exciting session by
simply learn
today we have a really interesting topic
for you in this video
we'll be discussing conditional
probability which is one of the most
important areas in probability theory
we'll start by talking about random
experiments and then move on to events
and sample space
then we'll try to understand the
multiplication rule with the help of an
example
after that we'll learn about dependent
events and the multiplication rule
associated with them
after that we learn about conditional
probability with the help of an example
so let's get started
what is a random experiment
let's say that you roll a square die and
there are six possible outcomes you can
get a number from one to six but it is
impossible to accurately predict the
outcome in mathematical theory we
consider only those experiments or
observations for which we know the set
of possible outcomes
also
it is important that predicting a
particular outcome is impossible
such an experiment where we know the set
of all the possible results but find it
impossible to predict any one particular
execution is a random experiment even if
a random experiment is repeated under
identical conditions the outcomes or
results fluctuate randomly sample space
and events the sample space associated
with the random experiment is the set of
all the possible outcomes
suppose you roll a die so the sample
space for a single throw up die will be
1 2 3 4 5 and 6.
an event is a subset of the sample space
or you can say it is an outcome of a
random experiment
getting a heads when we toss a coin is
an event now we will discuss about the
multiplication rule in probability
the multiplication rule says that when
two events are independent the
probability of both occurring
simultaneously is given by probability
of a intersection b will be equal to
probability of a into probability of b
let's understand this with the help of
an example if a cause is tossed twice
what will be the probability of getting
two heads so
in a single throw the probability of
getting a heads is one by two that is
point five
so
the probability of getting the two heads
in both the coins will be point five
into point five which is equal to zero
point two five let's look at another
example suppose a coin is flipped and a
die is rolled in the same time
so what will be the probability of
getting a head on the coin and four on
the dice
so
the probability of getting a heads as
discussed in the previous example will
be is equal to 0.5
and the probability of getting a 4 on a
single throw of die will be 1 by 6 since
there are 6 samples space and 1
favorable outcome so the probability of
getting a head on a coin and 4 on a die
will be equal to 0.5 into 0.16 which
will come out to be 0.80 now let's move
on to dependent events
two events are said to be dependent if
the outcome of the first event affects
the outcome of the second event
so that the probability is changed
let's understand this with the help of
an example
suppose you have a deck of card
the probability of drawing a card from a
deck of card is 1 by 52
now if you do not replace the card the
probability of drawing another card
changes to 1 by 51 another example of it
can be
parking at a no parking zone and getting
a ticket
when you park it in no parking zone the
probability of getting a ticket
increases there is a multiplication rule
associated with the dependent events
it says that when the two events are
dependent the probability of both
occurring is
given by this formula which is p a
intersection b is equal to probability
of a
into probability of b
a the slash reads
the probability that b occurs given that
a has already occurred let's look at an
example three cards are drawn from a
deck and are not replaced
what will be the probability of getting
three jacks so in this case
the probability of getting a jack out of
52 cards in the first draw will be 4 by
52 now after we have drawn the first
card
there are 51 cards left the probability
of getting a jack in a second and third
draw will be three by fifty one and two
by fifty respectively
so according to the formula the
probability of getting the three jacks
will be p point seven six into point
zero five eight into point zero four
will come out to be point zero zero one
seven six
now that we know all the basic concepts
in probability theory we'll move on to
conditional probability let a and b be
the two events associated with a random
experiment then the probability of is
occurrence under the condition that b
has already occurred
it's called the conditional probability
it is denoted by p a slash b
thus we have the a slash b is equal to p
a intersection b divided by p of b p a
slash b is read as probability of
occurrence of a given that b has already
occurred
similarly b b a can be called as
probability of occurrence of b given
that a has already occurred let's look
at an example in the recent study it was
found that the probability of a randomly
selected student is a girl is 0.51 and
is a girl and plays sports is 0.10 so if
the student is a female what is the
probability that she plays sports in
this case the probability that a student
is female and plays sport is 0.1
and the probability that a student is
female is 0.51 so the probability that
the students place a spot given that she
is a female will be 0.1 divided by 0.51
which will come out to be 0.1961 now we
are done with all the theories related
to conditional probability we'll move on
to the demo in excel let's look at the
problem statement suppose there are
group of hundred buyers out of which 70
purchased football and 40 purchased
hockey
however
there are 20 buyers who purchase both
football and hockey
determine the probability that a
randomly chosen buyer has purchased
football given that he also purchased
hockey
so this is a clear example of a
conditional probability
let's fill in this table
so the probability of purchasing a
football is 0.70
and that of hockey is 0.40
it is also given that there are 20
buyers who have purchased both football
and hockey
so point to zero is the probability of p
a intersection b
now if you remember the formula of the
conditional probability the a b is equal
to p a intersection b divided by p of b
where p a intersection b is the
probability of occurrence of both a and
b
p b is the probability of occurrence of
b
so we have all the values let's fit in
so this will be equal to this is cell e7
so we'll divide the cell e7
by cell
e6
we should come out to be 0.5
so the probability that randomly chosen
by has purchased football given that he
also purchased hockey is 0.5
with this we have come to the end of
this condition probability tutorial i
hope this was helpful if you have any
questions please put them in the comment
section also if you like the video
please subscribe to the simply end
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update thank you for watching
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here